la langue française n'est pas figée dans
le temps et parmi les 150 nouveaux mots
et expressions qui feront leur
apparition dans le petit Robert 2024 il
y aura complot sphère metaves et ghoster
gossez est-ce que ça vient du mot Ghost
en anglais Ghosty c'est quelque chose
que les gens vivent beaucoup leur
récemment c'est juste disparaître sur
les récentes additions dans le Larousse
et le petit Robert en disent long sur
les nouvelles technologies et la société
le verbe transitif mais genre fait son
entrée mais j'en ris je sais pas selon
le petit Robert mais j'en ai de ne pas
attribuer à quelqu'un le genre qui
correspond à son identité de genre c'est
dans l'air du temps c'est correct moi
aussi j'utilisais des mots mes parents
utilisaient pas plusieurs mots familiers
inspirés de l'anglais font aussi leur
apparition entre autres crash qui veut
dire coup de cœur ou encore basé on
pourrait dire éprouver de l'inquiétude
c'est sûr que c'est un intrus dans la
langue mais fullet il faut l'accueillir
on doit se montrer accueillant face à
ces mots-là personnellement si en tenait
qu'à moi il y en aurait pas il y en
aurait aucun de ces mots-là parce que je
préfère avoir l'équivalent français mais
on vit dans une réalité qui est tout
autre je te lève mes verres et mon
chapeau mieux je te lève mes mots le nom
propre David Goudreau fera son entrée
dans le petit Robert illustré 2024 le
slameur est poète québécois est qualifié
de fervent défenseur de la langue
française
il nous a été vraiment suggéré par par
des contacts québécois qui ont beaucoup
insisté donc on s'est vraiment pencher
sur des vies de goudron sur son œuvre si
les dictionnaires ouvrent leur page à
des mots des expressions et des noms
propres ce n'est pas tous les
francophones qui vont nécessairement les
utiliser alors allez-vous spoiler la fin
de ce reportage spoilé Patrick
Masbourian de 10 ce matin c'est
divulgar chez
quelqu'un qui vient de se taper de là ça
va
Spiller qui te dit la fin de l'épisode 1
avant que tu aies commencé toi-même une
question demeure ces nouveaux mots
donneront combien de points au jeu de
scrabble ici Louis Philippe radicada
Montréal
on est très heureux de l'accueillir sur
le plateau Guy Bertrand premier conseil
linguistique à Radio-Canada Radio
Télévision bonsoir bonsoir alors est-ce
que vous de façon générale pour voir
reprendre quelques exemples mais est-ce
que vous vous penchez plutôt
comme certaines personnes en disant on
est trop ouvert on fait rentrer trop
dans glisses dans le petit Robert ou au
contraire ça doit être fait comme ça
passer des mots qui sont employés oui
mais vous avez raison ça doit être fait
comme ça pour la bonne raison que le
Robert était dit d'ailleurs par au dAdam
donc ce n'est pas un ouvrage qui est
normatif très scriptif c'est un ouvrage
descriptif alors c'est un image un
portrait si on veut de la langue qui se
parle en 2024 puisque ce sont l'édition
2024 et c'est une chose très très
positive que de mettre le plus de mots
possible qui sont employés on met pas
des mots qui ne sont pas employés mais
la raison pour laquelle ces mots-là sont
dans le dictionnaire ce qui se sentent
employés et les gens qui ne connaissent
pas ceux qui sont d'une autre génération
par exemple qu'ils entendent les enfants
parler de gossistes et tout ça ils vont
ouvrir le dictionnaire ils vont savoir
ce que ça veut dire c'est à ça que ça
sert c'est pas pour nous dire dites ça
ce n'est pas un ouvrage qui est là pour
nous imposer quoi que ce soit c'est pour
nous faire un portrait de ce qu'on dit
c'est ce que plaide le petit Robert en
disant nous on ne sait pas un jugement
moral on dit pas qu'il faut qu'il ne
faut pas utiliser ces mots mais une fois
que des mots sont utilisés sont vivants
on veut le donner leur signification
voilà mais quand même ça donne un saut
d'acceptabilité quand je comprends ce
que vous dites et j'ai eu la même
réaction il y a de nombreuses années
parce que c'est comme si on disait le
mot identictionnaire parce qu'on dit ça
souvent le dictionnaire je peux le dire
mais ça c'est une attitude qu'il faut
changer c'est cette attitude là le
dictionnaire ce n'est pas un ouvrage qui
nous impose quoi que ce soit et nous que
c'est qu'est-ce que sont les mots alors
si on a l'attitude de ces dans le
dictionnaire donc je peux le dire moi je
réponds toujours à ces gens-là il y a
des mots extrêmement vulgaires qui sont
dans le dictionnaire depuis des
centaines d'années est-ce qu'on doit les
utiliser nécessairement et si on les
utilise dans quel contexte c'est la même
chose pour tous les mots ce que je
déplace et ça je vais vous le disais
tout de suite
pour ghoster par exemple il y a déjà
fantomiser qui existe il y a des mots
qui ont été trouvés ici des fois par
l'Office québécois de la langue
française des fois c'est le Bureau de la
traduction des fois c'est même
Radio-Canada on en a trouvé des mots ici
ces mots-là il ne les connaissent pas en
France des fois il les connaissent
l'info nuager qu'ils l'ont trouvé là
c'est vous je pense que c'est le fils je
vais pas me prononcer là-dessus mais il
me semble que ça vient d'ici l'exemple
qu'on donne beaucoup depuis ce matin
c'est divulgarie tout simplement
qui sont entrés en disant dites pas
parce qu'on en fait la promotion c'est
un beau mot alors c'est pas parce que
c'est pas parce que le mot je l'ai créé
mais c'est parce que je trouve qu'il est
il voit la peine qu'on l'utilise si on
peut voir la liste est-ce qu'il y en a
par ailleurs qui vous font sourcier plus
que d'autres là oui parce que je connais
pas Bader j'avais juste jamais entendu
ça de ma vie crash sur ce bizarre qu'on
a dit ça peut être un béguin je sais pas
exactement ce que c'est bien crash mais
la dame du Petit Robert dire ce matin
c'est un vieux mot du vieux français
qui avait été qui avait navigué vers
l'anglais et qui maintenant ça arrive
souvent sur le des fois c'est le sens
comme réalisé
ça ne voulait plus dire en français se
rendre compte de en anglais ça voulait
dire ça on l'a repris avec ce sens là on
le bannit longtemps puis on l'acceptait
c'est un peu la même chose pour tous les
mots ok donc ça vous choque pas ça